this is GM Daniel nerdinsky welcome to
the final round of the 2022 feed a world
Blitz Championship Magnus Carlson takes
on the Uzbek Phenom Grand Master
notrebec Abdul satoroff who defeated
Magnus in the 2021 rapid so the world
champion has a personal Vendetta against
the Uzbek Grandmaster we have a
traditional rui Lopez Magnus pushing the
pawn up to D3 as is very fashionable now
for the last couple of years and this is
still very traditional Waters and early
A4 by Magnus of course he threatens to
capture on B5 and forces black to make
an early commitment on the queen side
black and push the pawn up to B4 which
is exactly what noterbeck does but the
drawback of that move is that the C4
square is now available as a Transit
point for usually White's night and the
night does indeed come out to D2 and it
can continue on to C4 or as is more
traditional in the Rue Lopez it can move
back to F1 and then to G3 Carlson moves
his Pawn up to C3 grabbing more of the
center and preparing a potential
expansion with D3 D4 I'm sure that this
position has still occurred many many
times in Grand Master practice but
notrepeck is taking his sweet time
deciding where to put his light scored
bishop or whether to move it at all he
doesn't move it yet he Instead
buttresses The Pawn on B4 with Rook to
B8 and there's that classic Rook E1 move
of course the e-file is closed but it is
important for white to vacate the F1
Square for a knight maneuver to G3
Knight A5 by Notre back tickling the
bishop which moves back to A2 and now a
queen side expansion of his own with C7
C5 but Magnus he says I'm ready to fight
and he pushes the pawn up to D4 forcing
more commitments from black we have a
trade on C3 and norderbeck has nicely
positioned his Rook on B8 to benefit
from that he controls the open file but
now he faces a good amount of pressure
on the E5 Pawn I really like the way
that Magnus handled the opening he's
built up a time advantage and he's built
up a significant amount of pressure on
Black's Center noterbeck he can take on
D4 but then he's going to be left with a
very nasty backward Pawn on D6 that's
not really what you want on the Rue
Lopez and instead he chooses to keep the
tension Knight A5 back to C6 it goes and
he turns the tables on white he says two
can play at that game I'm pressuring
your D4 Pawn which Magnus pushes up to
D5 a big decision by the world champion
to close up the center and send black
snipe into Exile on B4 B4 might look
like a nice square but that Knight
doesn't really have a way back so it's
kind of a double-edged sword there as
notorbeck moves his other Knight over to
H5 but has he allowed a knight capture
on E5 no because he would have had a
night Fork on C2 at the end of a line
great calculation by these background
Master but Magnus look at what he does
there he pushes his Pawn up to A5 and he
severs the only link
that the night on B4 would have had with
his other pieces black could have played
A5 and supported that Knight instead the
Knight on B4 is now basically on its own
but Notre back says no it's not on its
own I've got my brother helping me he
moves his Knight down F4 and now the B4
Knight can jump into D3 and I think
Carlson is going to have to protect that
D3 square if he wants to keep the B4
Knight locked up the battle revolving
around the question of whether the
Knight on B4 is a weakness or is it
Black's greatest asset Carlson twirling
upon us he often does taking his time
he's built up a sizeable lead on the
clock you can afford to take even a
minute if he wants to he's still over
two minutes on the clock he can play
Knight D2 back to F1 he can move his
Rook up to E3 he's got a million ways he
can even play Rook to A3 he's got a lot
of ways to defend the D3 square and this
is a potentially crucial decision what
he really wants is a move that combines
the defense of the D3 square with a
build up of pressure on the B4 Knight
but I don't see a way to do both of
these things at this same time Carlson
continues to ponder his moves he's now
down 20 seconds on the clock he seems a
little bit frustrated here as he
continues to ponder this important
decision and finally he decides on
Knight D2 to F1 and the benefit of this
move is that the Knight on F4 can now be
eliminated if white so chooses bite the
dark squared bishop and now it's
notabeck's turn to take a think but he
doesn't take a long one he develops his
Bishop to G4 building up the pressure on
White's King side I like the way Notre
back has handled the last couple of
moves he's turned the tables on the
clock he's potentially turned the tables
in terms of who has the initiative but
Carlson just has a knack for getting out
of these situations and turning the
tables for the last time he's now down
30 seconds on the clock it's time for
the world champion to pick up the pace
noterbeck threatens to take the Knight
on F3 and then deliver a night Fork on
C2 a fork that was possible many moves
earlier if White had captured on E5 and
now Knight E3 is magnus's Choice a nice
move defending the C2 Square Notre by
keeping the tension dropping his Bishop
back to H5 and there's that rookie A3
move we talked about earlier Magnus
preparing to encircle the Knight on B4
by moving The Rook to B3 and then maybe
getting the dark squared Bishop involved
via D2 or A3 but Notre back Queen to C7
Magnus ignores Bishop D2 the bishop on
C4 is nicely protected by the Knight on
E3 look at how nicely Magnus is arranged
his minor pieces all of the critical
squares are covered C2 is covered D3 is
covered F3 is covered Notre back he's
got very impressive looking pieces but I
don't see a way for him to make inroads
into White's position and the clock is
ticking literally and figuratively the
clock is also taking for the B4 Knight
and a big decision by these background
Master he decides to take on F3 and I
think he wants to follow up with Knight
B4 to C2 deflecting deflecting the E3
knight from its defense of the C4 bishop
and thereby solving the problem once and
for all of his B4 Knight and there he
goes Knight takes it to Queen takes C4
things looking pretty good here for
another back as he finally eliminates
his B4 Knight And Trades it off for the
C4 our Bishop now we've got a material
balance but here goes magnus's Knight
it's threatening to move to F5 Suddenly
It's Black's Queen
Suddenly It's Black's Queen that's now
in a fair bit of trouble as The Rook on
D1 menacingly x-rays it and white
threatens Knight F5 Notre back has to
defend that square or move his Queen
back so that Knight F5 doesn't come with
a fork he moves it back to C5 I thought
he could have played G6 in order to to
protect that F5 score once and for all
but instead he has allowed the Knight to
jump into F5 and now he's starting to
think that was a questionable decision I
think Magnus might be taking over the
initiative the bishop moves up to G5 it
protects the Knight on F4 which Magnus
could capture but first he knocks the
bishop off of G5 an excellent move by
the world champion as he burns the
Flames of the initiative H4 saying get
off me get off G5 and if the bishop
leaves G5 it leaves the Knight on F4
more vulnerable than ever and the only
reason the black is not losing a pawn
here immediately is because the queen on
C5 is keeping in contact with the A3
Rook which is protected by the queen on
F3 but things looking very precarious
for Notre back they were looking
precarious for magnus's clock though
he's under 30 seconds and he moves Rock
up to C3 oh and now the D6 spawn is
potentially going to fall and if that
pawn Falls it is really the linchpin of
Black's entire structure white will have
a monster past spawn on D5 I don't see a
way for Notre back to keep in contact
with that pawn and he does it he takes
on A5 that's a pretty meaningless pawn
and before taking on D6 look at how
patiently the world champion handles
these positions first he plays the move
G3 knocking the Knight off of f4 and
Notre Becky has to continue circling
back instead he decides to sack on D5 a
desperation measure he takes D5 he wants
to push E4 and open up a discovered
attack on White's Rook but I don't buy
it and neither does Magnus a calm
retreating move with the Rook a
discovered attack of his own on the
queen on A5 and I think Magnus is just
winning a full piece I think Notre
blundered that move he's down to 14
seconds things looking good here for the
world champion Notre back has no choice
but to move his Queen away and Magnus
he's toying with him playing with his
food Rook to see one another in-between
move forcing the queen further back into
Exile and once the queen moves back to
A7 or be six now Magnus captures the
Knight on D5 he is up a full piece and
he is about to send uh the Flames onto
the king side look at that Knight on F5
he can go Queen G4 he can take on D6 but
first he takes care of business by
protecting the bishop on E2 Notre back
down to his last seconds Rook after d8
and King G2 such a typical Magnus move
he just calmly improves his position and
now he sends The Rook down to C6 this
game is over Red Rover he takes on D6
with a fork everything's collapsing
gears goes another one and Notre Becky
is a full piece down and he extends his
hand so that means Magnus Carlson with a
fist bump and a hand wave he wins the
2022 feed a world Blitz championship in
style what a final game for the world
champion and if you enjoyed this video
make sure to click the link in the
playlist for more of these Blitz videos
thank you for watching
thank you